oh hello everyone how are you guys doing
hope you guys are having a wonderful day
and today we are here with another video
so today's video will be on optimizing
or maximizing the utility or GE slot so
a problem that I see with a lot of
people that don't like to merge like I
do is that you just throw away your G's
law it's like they just sit there empty
and to me as a merger I kind of see that
and I'm a little saddened by it so I'm
gonna go ahead and try to help out your
average PVM or skilar that doesn't see
any use in merging they find it too hard
to get into like they don't understand
what's going on I'm going to go ahead
and show you guys a few ways that you
guys can utilize your GE slots or
without much effort at all so let's get
on into it before we get into it though
I just want to preface this by saying
that a lot of the methods I'm going to
show you guys here in a second will not
be methods of flipping if you don't know
what flipping is flipping is a way of
merging that is just buying and selling
items based on the margin this will not
be that for the most part most of these
will involve some sort of manual labor I
mean if you want to call runescape
manual labor that will involve some of
that that will increase the price of
items and so it's definitely worth it
it's all of these being more profitable
than zora compared to time spent and
money made so just keep that mine the
first method I'm going to show you guys
here today is a farming method so
basically with farming a lot of people
don't like to actually make the saplings
themselves so this is going to be a
method of what you can go about doing
that and just pretty much buying the
margins on this so you do need a farming
level with this the farming level is
identical to the seed that you'll be
using so if you start doing this with
you seeds and you need sixty magic treat
75 same with all the fruit trees and
that holds true there so what you want
to do to go ahead and find a margin
going over to the GE you can type in
whatever seed you wish to see for this
example that I'm gonna go ahead and show
you guys magic seed since they'll
probably have the biggest margin so I'm
gonna go ahead and buy one this is not
the price you want to buy them for if
you don't have flipping works pay
attention 135 oh four seven as you saw
there it's not the price you want to buy
it for you're going to want to buy these
for these sell price so you're gonna
want to buy them for 134k on the dot at
least in this example obviously price
has changed so you'll have to bind
someone to find out what the price
during the time that you are doing yours
so as you can see from their magic
saplings buy for 139 K which means that
this is a profit of five K just by
putting a magic seed into a magic
sapling also with you see it's
considering its a lower level less money
to put into the seeds obviously gonna
have less of margin here it's 2 K it's
typically three to four so I don't want
to use that as an example but you guys
can see that there with that being said
I'm going to go ahead and show you guys
how easy it is to make a sapling if you
guys don't know what goes into it so
you're gonna want to go ahead and buy
your seed and once you have it move on
over to the bank once at the bank you're
going to want to have a trowel in your
inventory and and/or a filled plant pot
and a watering can so alright so you're
gonna want to fill up your watering cans
probably using humidify and basically
all you have to do is just put a you
seed in your inventory or in the plant
bucket and then water it and then within
a couple minutes it turns into the used
sapling but I mean that's no skin off
your back you don't have to sit here
wait can do whatever else you want while
it sits in your bank so there you go
easy 5k made there if you can do magic
seeds or depending on the margins
anywhere else so now the second method
that I have for you guys is kind of a
different one it's something that not a
lot of people would think of I'm pretty
surprised I found it myself I just kind
of random but I was checking margins one
day and happened to find this so it's
something that's held true for a while
at this point so basically what you're
going to want to do is just buy rune
darts P it's a very easy way to fill up
one GE slot I think about 10,000 of
these are bought and sold every hours so
there's obviously a ton coming into and
out of the game I'm gonna go ahead and
answer buy one and to sell it obviously
don't buy for the buy price again so as
you guys can see with that sale price we
sell it off for 1161 and what we do with
rune darts is then we will end up
cleaning the rune darts P and selling
them on as regular rune darts and as you
can see you can sell them off for eleven
ninety so that means you make twenty
nine GP in this instance typically it's
around I guess I would be around an
average but considering you can buy you
know five to ten thousand an hour it's
not you know it's not that bad it's
definitely something you'd want to throw
your money into if you have money laying
around if you guys don't know how to go
ahead and unpause in something I'll
demonstrate with my dragon dagger here
but you can do this with a dart as well
all's you need it's a cleaning cloth
which you can buy from the gran exchange
go ahead and use it on your item and
boom poisons gone just like that you can
do that too the whole second one click
so you do not have to worry about that
at all so another way that you can go
ahead and make money is by looking up
malediction or odium or you guys can do
this as well on OS buddy pretty easily
you guys can just use the recommended
price but you won't know exactly what
price to go off of this helps me out a
lot but as you guys can see here you
guys can buy malediction shards three
four three mil malediction CR 2 4 355 k
and i malediction shard one for 133 k as
you can see here just go off of the
lowest price sometimes they're little
mix I don't know how that particularly
works but just go off the lowest price
since that's obviously what something is
sold for you can buy the malediction
shard 3 for 3 mil the malediction char 2
for 311 K and the malediction shard 1
for 132 K in total that adds up to being
around three point four three mil and
from there you can go ahead and sell off
the malediction work 43.77 yielding you
essentially a three hundred forty k
profit or so so that is obviously a
pretty good profit and on top of that it
does take a little bit of time so you
guys do you have to realize that but as
someone that doesn't merge a lot you
probably won't be too bothered by that
however it's just something i want to
preface this by saying same holds true
for odium wards as you guys can see here
odium wards if you off the lowest price
you have 2.6 here 2.9 there which equals
5.5 and from there you add on another
900 k puts you up to around 6.4 and you
can sell off the odium ward for 6.8
yielding you at 400 K profit there so
that's always going to be a margin
that's worth doing you'll have to slowly
buy these if you insta buy these this
isn't going to work obviously because
then everyone just be into buying them
and making tons of money but in the end
they always hold a decent margin because
not a lot of people if you don't have
something like GE tracker know exactly
what the prices are and knowing the
exact price can be the difference
between breaking even and wasting all of
your time or actually making 3 to 400 K
relatively easily so back on over to the
game if you guys do not know how to
charge odium wards or malediction wards
basically what you're gonna want to do
start off at Edgeville or if you have
the ability to teleport to an takara
which will require completing desert
treasure and having the teleportation
method there whether it be a tab or an
actual mage cash
go ahead and use that if not you're
going to want to head and use the edge
of a lever from there you will be
teleported all the way out here if
you're at annacarl
just remember you're gonna want to go
right here and if you're at the deserted
keep you're going to also want to run
all the way over here once you're here
go ahead and use your odium shards or
malediction shards on the lava pool and
it will be made into a ward and then you
can sell it off for a little bit of
profit next up is something that's a
little bit different and it does have a
skill requirement of 60 runecrafting
which is why I can't show you in-game
because neither my counts of 60
runecrafting but eventually in the
future I will get it up to go ahead and
do that so if you have GE tracker you
can check all these like margins by
going to item sets I'm crafting I'm
gonna go ahead and go here just so I can
show you guys if any of these boots
actually have a good margin right now
and my internet is incredibly slow back
home so I apologize as you guys can see
here malediction odium Ward's have a
pretty decent margin also on top of that
you turtle boots which is going to be
one of my examples primordial have a
smaller margin but sometimes these can
reach 300k margins and with how frequent
these things are bought and sold and the
fact that you can get crystals
relatively easily makes it a very good
money make the method so alright so the
next method that I'm going to show you
guys is something that I cannot do in
game however I'm going to item sets and
crafting right now on GE tracker to go
ahead and show you guys it because I do
not have sixty runecrafting on either my
accounts so yeah we have that going on
for me but another thing that you guys
can do is eternal boots or primordial
Zoar anything around the sort so if you
guys ever have the time to go ahead and
check in the granite shades it's always
worth it to check and see how eternal
crystals form or do crystals and big
asian crystals are price compared to
what the actual boots are so in this
case you can make 140k off of buying an
eternal crystal infinity boots and
putting them together which takes
relatively no time at all and in that
just 5 seconds that you spent getting
them out of the bank you made 140 K so
it's pretty easy and eternal crystals
and all the crystals I guess in general
are in relatively decent supply and
you'll always be able to grab some
infinity but it's pretty easily so
that's another money-making method I'm
going to go ahead and show you guys the
next one now from there the next one
will be potion decanting so this is on G
tracker site as well it makes it
relatively easily one thing that you do
have to realize whenever you're shorting
through these is to make sure that you
sort by like approximate profit per one
but also kind of sort out the ones that
you know aren't going to have any bought
or sold ie same Rock bruise or hunter
potions because they obviously have a
big margin because there's no one buying
the potions however as you guys can see
here saradomin potions and super
defenses actually have a huge margin if
you are able to buy two in one dose
however one of the things I would
recommend more is looking for three dose
ones even though it may be lower profit
one in two dose ones are relatively not
sold anywhere near as much as super
energy threes I would imagine so that's
something you can check out if you guys
want to go ahead and do that and game
I'm gonna show you guys how you can do
that now what you would do for example
is go ahead and go to the grand exchange
and go ahead and buy yourself one brew
or whatever potion you wish to test out
and go ahead and see what these sell
price is then take this price and divide
it into four so you can understand what
the dose prices so in this instance the
dose price is two one one four which
means that if you can go ahead and buy
pseudo and brews for under six three
four two you'll actually make profit off
of just decanting them at this guy over
here so what you want to go ahead and do
is see what the price is on saradomin
potions 3 the insta buy price is not
going to be the one you'll want to use
as I said earlier however that one it's
almost exactly what it should be and
you're going to want to go ahead and
sell it so from here as I said it should
be six three four two however its six
one six zero which means if you were to
make these into threes you're making or
if you were to make these into fours
you're making about 200 coins off of
every saradomin brew you purchase so
from there all you have to do is go
ahead and just leave a decently high pie
offer in which I'm going to do now
because that's a really good margin and
just wait and then once they're all done
all's you have to do is go over here to
this guy in the grant exchange I don't
imagine most people know this and just
go ahead and decant I don't have more
than one potion my inventory so it can't
but that's the way that you would go
ahead and do that alright so that will
be it for today's video hopefully you
guys enjoyed hopefully some of these
tips were helpful and you haven't heard
of them before if you guys found this
video hopefully go ahead and leave a
like if you guys have any other ways I
guess of which you could utilize ze
slots and want to let people know feel
free to in a comment down below if you
guys want to see more of these videos as
soon as they go live make sure hit that
sub button
and yeah hit up the Twitter in the
description and o7 helpers in runescape
so other than